most houses take wild beasts for their
sigils calling themselves bears lions or
stags as if a cloth banner could make
them so that isn't the way of house
Tarly our residual is the Huntsman
pulling his bow and it isn't some idle
fencing as soon as a son of house Tarly
can hold a spoon he gets a bow as soon
as the boy consider a horse his father
takes him on a hunt they returned with a
stag buck aboard a brace of pheasant
even if it takes days even if it takes a
week even if it takes the boys whole
life horn Hill is ours a fitting home
from one of the oldest and most
honorable families of the reach legend
has it that Holland the hunter and
herndon of the horn
two sons of Gotha green hand raised the
castle in the Age of Heroes and shared a
home and a wife for a hundred years
most of the great houses about such
nonsense about their origins least my
family doesn't claim some long-lost
ancient crown like the rest of them
house Tarly breeds soldiers not kings
when house gardener ruled the rich we
served them well and loyally when house
gardener died and Aegon gave the reach
to their stewards the Tyrells we served
them well and loyally we know our place
even if the Tyrell women don't an egg on
Sun faced rebellion from the vulture
king of Dorne my ancestor savage
santolli led the royal forces on a
vulture hunt hearts pain our ancestral
Valyrian sword and a pry of our husk
soon ran red from point to hilt with
rebel blood
and Robert Baratheon rebelled against
Aires I led the Tyrell van and handed
him his only defeat in the war were
Ashford but a hunter knows that a
moment's slip can cost him the game
Great Houses have fallen from a single
weak air
Samwell looked like a son when he was
born but he grew up plump and soft as a
daughter I catch him in the kitchen shot
it cakes into his ever-growing mouth or
reading in the garden when he was
supposed to be training
I brought masters of arms from all over
Westeros to make a man of him he slept
in chainmail bathed in Bulls blood was
dressed in his mother's clothes and
paraded through the castle to shame him
into valor
he only grew fatter one more Craven
I despaired of the future of our house
until my wife gave me another boy
[ __ ] a real son and worthy heir or he
would have been his Sam was on squatting
in his way
one morning I had Sam brought into the
woods outside the castle I told him he
given me know caused at his own him but
heart's pain should go to a man strong
enough to wield her and Sam wasn't
worthy to touch her hilt either he would
take the black and renounce all claim to
his brother's sword and title or I will
hunt him down like that piggy was
of course faced in danger and exertion
it shows the cowards path and waddle
north to the wall some may call me cruel
for what I did but I don't care I am
responsible for her stylee as my father
was before me and his father before him
if the hunter returns with empty hands
his family stars
if the warrior carries an empty scabbard
his home burns has Tolly has stood for
thousands of years it will not fall on
my watch no matter how many tears my
family sheds